what's up guys my name is zacherno strap
yourselves in this is going to be a long
one today we're going to be talking
about the game engine series we're going
to be talking about hazel where it's
going in the future direction of this
because i've had the last few weeks to
kind of reflect on
what i'm doing with my life what i'm
doing with this series and
uh
this video is going to be about where
we're heading now it's very likely that
this video will upset a few people uh
i'm sure that this will not fit the
ideas that everyone had going into this
series
but hopefully the reasons i provide will
reassure you that i'm not making this
decision lightly and
overall it's going to be for the best
and for those of you who are completely
unaware of what's going on i am making a
game engine called hazel and i'm also
developing a video series called the
game engine series in which i show
myself
writing basically every single line of
code that goes into making a game engine
and that is coincidentally also called
hazel even though the game engine that
i'm making along with a team is very
different than the video series the game
engine series so this particular video
is going to be structured in two parts
basically there's going to be the
explanation and the future and then
we're going to dive in and spend the
majority of this video actually planning
literally like the rest of the series
and
every single component from a high level
that is going to go into this game
engine series and you'll see that i have
nicely divided this video into chapters
so that you can navigate it more easily
so to cut a long story short basically
the game engine series version of hazel
is becoming hazel 2d yes that means that
we will not be adding any kind of 3d
rendering 3d physics 3d anything really
as part of this game engine series my
version of hazel that i'm developing
along with a team that of course already
is 3d and that's accessible by patrons
that will remain 3d and it will contain
both 2d and 3d functionality as it
currently does now and we're going to
keep working on that if you're suddenly
oh so shocked then stick around because
i'm going to explain why i'm making
these decisions and what the motivation
is behind them so first of all when i
say no 3d in hazel 2d in this game
engine series version of hazel i'm not
referring to the fact that it will not
have any concept of 3d space what i'm
talking about is that it's not going to
have a 3d renderer that will render
meshes 3d models and it will not have
like a 3d physics engine or anything
like that currently at the moment this
game engine series version of hazel that
is on github
that actually does support the concept
of 3d space because of course you can
create like an entity and it's got an x
y and a z coordinate it doesn't just
have an x and a y coordinate like you
would see if it was truly 2d it is in
fact still in 3d space we also have
perspective projection and we have an
editor camera that does in fact exist in
3d space and you can control it as if
you were flying through 3d space so all
of that is in fact there that will
remain there but we're not going to be
officially at least taking it into
more of like a 3d game engine sense
basically my idea is to take hazel 2d
the game engine series version of hazel
from now on i'm going to call hazel 2d
the game engine series version of hazel
so just remember that and if i say hazel
from now on i'm specifically referring
to like the full version of hazel the
patreon version of hazel my version of
hazel not the game engine series my goal
with hazel 2d is to make it an
absolutely brilliant 2d game engine that
means that we will be focusing on
implementing pretty much every system
imaginable that you can think of that
you would like to have in a 2d game
engine this series after all is called
the game engine series not the how to
write a 3d renderer that is goodbye 2021
standards series and it's just becoming
far too apparent with the work that i've
been doing on hazel the real hazel
just how much time it would take to
actually
teach and record videos on every single
line of code that goes into something
like that
and the thing is at the end of the day
not everyone is interested in 3d
rendering i think the game engine series
is a bit misleading if
90 of it would be 3d rendering and then
all the other systems fit in at some
point then not to mention it's going to
keep going for literally the rest of my
life which it looks like it probably
will anyway so my point is the scope is
just far too large and i would rather
focus on the engine in a more holistic
approach rather than focusing on this
kind of massive part of it now that
being said and i have mentioned this
before like the scope of the 2d
rendering and the 2d games that we're
making you know i'm not i'm not
picturing 80s space invaders or
something like that over the last few
weeks i've been playing two games on my
nintendo switch celeste and hollow
knight now these are both 2d games so to
speak for those of you who haven't
played these games by the way i highly
recommend them they are both excellent
now celeste on one hand is a little bit
more simple in the way that it renders
everything hollow knight on the other
hand is very much a a great example of a
2d game in 3d space because the whole
thing is made up of so many different
layers there's so much parallaxing going
on the art in that game is just it's
almost overwhelming for me to look at
realizing how much work has gone into
that it's also a great example of
combining 2d art with engine generated
things such as like particle effects
lighting and other things i think that
hollow knight is absolutely a great
benchmark a great goal to work towards
as to the kinds of 2d games i want to be
able to create with hazel 2d so let's
talk about why
this change is happening i mean i think
that a lot of you probably can already
guess that it's a lot of work to try and
complete quote unquote a 3d game engine
i mean
first of all if you look at other
engines that are currently out there in
the wild
they're not completed i mean i would
call them completed in the sense that it
really depends how you define that like
what does completing a 3d game engine
mean well i guess to me it means it's at
a state where you can ship like actually
ship a complete game with it that
includes all of the things we have grown
accustomed to being in a game so like
you know if you don't support audio but
you have great graphics i wouldn't
really call that a complete game engine
because usually games have sound the
other problem is that like the term 3d
game engine i mean
you could argue that what we have in
hazel 2d is a 3d game engine because it
it is in 3d space
so like it really depends if you kind of
picture something really simple that's
in 3d space or you look at a 3d game
such as i don't know call of duty or why
is it so hard to come up with 3d games
on the spot battlefield ratchet and
clank
just like
3d games guys my point being that 3d
games in 2021 are pretty like complex in
both the interaction
with the world
but then also the actual rendering
technology that goes into them that's
kind of what we're trying to do with
hazel with the real hazel like that's
that's hard enough as it is
but then to convert that into a video
tutorial series is both i think mostly
unhelpful for people who are actually
trying to do this because i don't think
they'd be sitting through
videos like that unless it's for
entertainment
um but also
there's just just too much time has to
go into that i mean to be blunt there is
just a lot there's too much time to go
into that time that i would rather spend
actually making the game engine because
as i mentioned that's a difficult enough
task as it is the goal of the game
engine series as i mentioned is to make
a game engine and to bring it into that
kind of production quality state what i
mean by that is to get it to the point
where i would happily ship a 2d game
with it on steam a lot has to happen in
order to achieve this a lot of mostly
non-rendering related work and we're
going to discuss all of that here today
so that's the first reason just the fact
that the scope is absolutely enormous
the second reason
is mostly because i don't necessarily
consider myself a career academic so
first and foremost i see myself as a
software engineer i see myself as
someone working on
hazel working on a game engine i
actually want to
make the game engine and i want to make
games with it and i want to ship them
and distribute them and let people play
them
like a piece of art i'm an engineer
making art i mean that's the entire goal
of hazel to create a game engine that
can make games and not just an engine
that i can use to make games but an
engine that
well everyone can use to make games if
they want which you know that's
debatable the actual like step-by-step
tutorial series aspect of of hazel
that's secondary i started the game
engine series because i wanted to teach
people how to make game engines but i
also wanted to make a game engine first
and foremost don't get me wrong that
doesn't mean that i don't consider the
educational aspect of what i'm doing
important or that i don't care about it
i definitely do but first and foremost
there needs to be a game engine that
i've made in order to teach how to make
game engines and
that is my primary goal the other
interesting factor with that is the fact
that like
i mean the amount of complexity that
would go into a 3d game engine and just
the level of nicheness like i mean this
series is already pretty niche but i
mean if you consider trying to teach
someone how to
how to make a complex 3d renderer
in the context of a 100 plus episode
game engine series like
the
the amount of people i feel that will
actually get to that point and will
benefit from that
it's just it just gets smaller and
smaller and trying to do that on youtube
like i definitely don't even think that
youtube is a good platform for that this
is just way too specific that's why i
mentioned in my recent bloom video that
i would be creating a general purpose 3d
rendering course that won't be on
youtube and won't apply specifically to
the hazel codebase so those are kind of
the two main reasons because i think the
scope is just enormous and also because
i want to spend more of my time actually
making hazel and seeing what that can
lead to what that can become rather than
focusing on a step-by-step video
tutorial series which probably isn't the
best way to
help people who are at that level anyway
at the moment the hazel team that works
on proper hazel the patreon version of
hazel
there's eight of us now these are mostly
volunteers although some are on payroll
but that should give you a bit of an
idea as to the effort that goes into
hazel it's definitely not just me
patreon is what makes hazel possible in
the first place not just hazel but hazel
2d and the entire game engine series and
hopefully your support will contribute
to converting some more of these
volunteers to actually being on payroll
so that we can achieve greater things
lots of the technology from hazel will
make its way back to hazel 2d because of
course the entire engine is not all
about rendering so not everything we
develop in hazel is effectively close
source and only accessible by patrons
who help support the project okay so
hopefully all of that makes sense if you
have any questions about any of this
please leave a comment below i'll we'll
be happy to try and reply to as many of
you as possible but let's move on to the
planning portion of this video and we
will discuss
how we're going to make hazel 2d the
rest of it okay so this morning i
actually sat down and i wrote a list off
the top of my head of every single game
engine system that i could think of that
we are going to be putting into hazel 2d
it's right here in front of me
as i said strap yourselves in this is
going to take a very long time i'll try
and be kind of quick this is more of an
overview it's i'm not going to be too
low level 2 implementation detailing
it's just going to be specifically all
of like the overview of everything
that's going to go into this
okay so let's begin with the renderer
now the renderer which already exists to
some extent right
this renderer needs to be able to
support 2d rendering now what do we mean
by 2d rendering well first and foremost
by 2d rendering i'm referring to the
ability to basically render triangles or
quads i mean most of the stuff that we
render in 2d if you consider it as being
two-dimensional we usually render it on
a quad now as i mentioned hollow knight
is kind of an inspiration for where this
series is going so i'm going to be using
it as an example from time to time this
is just a random screenshot i pulled off
of the internet so if we look at this
frame here there are so many things
going on but the main gist of it is that
everything that we see here is basically
a quad with a texture applied to it if
you've been following along with the
series you'll obviously understand this
i'm not going to spend too much time on
this but my point is that like pretty
much everything that we see here really
is a quad right i mean i don't know to
what extent the background is separated
from everything else but the other thing
with hollow knight is that it is in fact
made up of layers right so we have like
this kind of main layer which is useless
me drawing in 2d but we have this kind
of foreground layer there might be some
other things in the foreground particles
are definitely floating around literally
everywhere we have many background
layers if you look at this from top down
instead of from like the side like this
then what you'll see is literally like
layers like that right so it is in fact
in 3d space this is our z kind of access
right
so that's what we're seeing over here
but again everything is made up of these
quads and so when we uh look at our
render and we think about what a
renderer needs to support in 2d it is
just overwhelmingly it needs to be able
to render textured quartz that's the
most important thing now currently we
are batching these together kind of on
demand dynamically every frame into a
large vertex buffer that is a pretty
good way of doing it there are some
issues with that we could look into
using instance rendering we could you
look into using like a geometry shader
to generate quads although that's
becoming more and more old-fashioned uh
as time goes on maybe like the new mesh
shader can be used for that
uh you know gathering those vertices in
compute potentially like there's a lot
of different ways to think about
rendering quads but for now we basically
have this idea of a batch renderer um
and that is
that's going to get us like 90 of the
way there basically and i don't think
we'll run into performance issues
anytime soon
now
that's all fine being able to render
this stuff but what about being able to
manage our textures a little bit better
in the form of texture atlases right so
a texture atlas or a sprite sheet
we also i think have covered those kind
of um those are basically ways to uh put
more than one texture effectively into
like a single texture
file well i mean it's nothing to do with
files really when you create a texture
on the gpu instead of making it like 32
by 32 and then having like six of those
you can effectively put that
put all of those textures into a larger
texture and then you know map them here
so a good example actually is for like
font rendering but of course you can use
it for absolutely anything and if you
look at a game like minecraft that's a
great example because people have a lot
of exposure to like the texture packs in
minecraft and what they look like that
sprite sheet there is a great example of
a texture atlas because our gpu can
really usually only deal with 32 texture
units or texture slots at once meaning
that if we want to render more than that
amount of textures we need to split up
our draw calls which interferes with
that batch render anyway this isn't
really a rendering tutorial
but the idea is we need to have texture
atlases now this isn't just used for
like sprites or 2d graphics um another
good example in 3d use is for shadow
maps if you have like a point light with
many different shadow maps like one for
basically each each uh each face of your
kind of cube map right a very common
technique is to pile those into
a single texture and in fact you can
combine multiple point lights that are
in your scene and put all of their depth
maps into like a single texture that's
also very common so this is definitely
not like tech that's only used for 2d
stuff but it's going to be very
important for 2d rendering now
moving on
animation right so
2d animation of course
um
usually that's done by having sprite
sheets so you create it in whatever
software you want to create it in you
could even create an animation of
something in like after effects and
export it as an image sequence if you
want again usually they are in fact
combined into sprite sheets to kind of
save on that unless they're extremely
high resolution um it's also possible to
use back at ea i
actually created like a sprite animation
format that we used for our mobile
engine which was for
uh you know
i guess higher quality kind of
animations that spreadsheets would have
been annoying to use for and that worked
by delta encoding between frames so it's
a little bit similar to like video
codecs although not that complex and you
basically had multiple frames of
animation and there was various
compression that happened on it but the
key thing was uh only recording the
pixels that have changed basically and
then having like keyframes like you
would in a um in like a video codec so
that's also an option that's probably
better if you have huge textures because
that way you don't have to um you know
have
you can't have sprite sheets of 4k
textures but usually you wouldn't really
if it's that big you you really need to
think of something else um usually these
animations are quite small so they fit
nicely into like a sprite sheet and
everything's fine so i don't think we'll
do anything fancy like that uh i think
we'll be okay with sprite sheets for the
most part for animation but we obviously
want tools for that we'll get to like
the editor portion of this a bit later
as well this is strictly like what the
renderer needs to support so yeah
animation um the other thing is uh
basically
the ability to have custom shaders
and materials right so in 3d we're
obviously used to having a material for
pretty much everything for pretty much
every object in our game but for 2d
since most things are just textures on
quads we can kind of get away with
not really
um i guess using uh this whole wide
variety of different materials and
possibly even different shaders however
you may still want to have
custom shaders for things so so an
example of the top of my head for a 2d
game would be like in celeste um you can
go underwater and then everything's kind
of wavy you know and i don't i don't
know how they did that but i don't think
it's you know they made like some kind
of character animation of it being all
wavy right i don't think that's it's
probably just a shader effect uh so
doing stuff like that as an example
that's something that would more or less
require like a custom shader or at least
some other maybe built-in engine
material that would handle like a
special case of rendering or something
like that um
i guess another example is even like
because remember you can have layers and
so if you have layers like i'm just i'm
just uh picturing like you know frosted
glass if you had frosted glass and there
was stuff behind it which was obviously
in the background kind of like the depth
was greater then you'd have the
parallaxing effect which means this will
move with the camera and so therefore
you might want to blur like this this
might be like an additional path that
goes on top of things that would in fact
blur this area
you know so stuff like that
very kind of desirable if you get into
the more advanced effects uh so i
definitely want to be able to support
that now finally um
i hope i haven't missed anything major
but basically post processing effects so
post effects so what i mean by that is
basically things like bloom
things like color grading
color grading
there's many more things that you might
want um but the point is you know those
there's no reason why those have to not
exist in 2d they do exist in a lot of 2d
games and uh i guess if you're making
like a really nice polish 2d game i mean
you can even have like auto exposure for
different rooms and stuff like that hdr
rendering all that stuff we do that
anyway i think we're doing hdr rendering
it doesn't really matter it's not not a
big change but um
you know that kind of stuff is also
really important if you are kind of
shooting towards like a higher fidelity
uh i guess 2d game so that's also
necessary that is pretty much
where i see the renderer and again i
think we've got the first two more or
less implemented so it's really more
about like you know animation and then
this stuff which custom shaders and post
processing can come later animation is
pretty important um we'll probably focus
that sometime soon
all right that's the renderer that's
part one now the next thing that i want
to talk about is scripting
because in my opinion this is probably
uh
one of the most important things
um in in actually making a game now
first and foremost actually with all
this stuff i just want to mention
that
this is in no particular order and this
is not this has nothing to do with the
order that we're going to be progressing
in this is just everything that needs to
be done basically right and i will be
organizing this into like a trello board
or some kind of online medium so that
you can actually look at it and you can
also track the progress of this over
time
and i will probably even start tying it
to commits and to branches and stuff as
that stuff goes in so scripting
now
um
scripting is a way for us to basically
create and define all of the behavior
for what our what actually happens in
our game during runtime right so um
there's a few different ways to do that
um
the way that i've kind of chosen for
hazel is c sharp and there are a few
reasons for that so first of all c sharp
is an extremely capable programming
language it's also very fast right um i
mean visual studio is written in c sharp
uh
frostbite like the frostbite editor
frosted that is written in c sharp and
it uses the sql space engine uh like c
sharp is is a very capable programming
language obviously unity uses c-sharp as
well for scripting but i'm just talking
about the language overall i think it's
a really good language i've had a lot of
experience with it and i really like it
i think it's great and this is my engine
so lol
however there are there are other
languages you could consider
um the thing with lua is that like lu is
also very popular in the games industry
less so these days in the past it used
to be more but the thing is like i
personally like for something like space
invaders or like i don't know snake
small kind of arcade games it was
totally fine but when you start thinking
about a large game that maybe could be
worked on
by a team for like years
i just don't see myself using lower for
that so because of that
we use um we use c sharp on in real
hazel land and i think that it's also
going to be perfect to integrate
obviously into hazel 2d because why
wouldn't it be now
visual scripting
is also a possibility um i won't talk
about that now
but that's also obviously a system that
can be used it's not bad at all a lot of
people are afraid of that i'm an
engineer though so it's hard for me to
justify using a visual scripting system
i feel more comfortable with code i feel
like i can get more done i like using
the keyboard like it's it's just it's
just fits me a little bit better but the
thing with c sharp and what actually
constitutes behavior and how you define
behavior in a game engine like this
stuff is mostly tied directly to the ecs
the entity component system i'm not even
going to be talking about like ecs stuff
we've already got that and we're just
going to build more and more components
for basically everything we need as time
goes on it's not something that i think
we need to really talk about but
the thing with c sharp again is that
really what you're doing for the most
part is interacting with the ecs when
you interact with the game engine right
so what i mean by that is i mean think
of a think of a c-sharp script right you
would uh if you wanted to you know
respond to the user input and then move
an entity you would retrieve the
transform component of the entity
uh and you know in the onupdate function
if input is keypressed blah blah blah
then change that translation of the
transform component right that's how you
move stuff or maybe if you have physics
you'll apply a linear impulse to
something again you get the rigid body
component and you apply the impulse so a
lot of this stuff i mean you also
instantiate entities and prefabs uh
delete entities
like that kind of stuff so that's all
ecs stuff right i mean obviously you can
have an entire meta game an entire like
program running as part of your c-sharp
scripts that manages all these other
systems you could write a multi-threaded
ai model or something like that that
will determine these things like there's
a lot of like stuff that gets built on
top of that but at the end when you're
actually interfacing with the game
engine you are mostly not fully but
mostly concerned with the ecs so that's
the kind of stuff that needs to be able
to be readily accessible by c-sharp
now um
the other thing is reflection so we want
to be able to
basically um look at the c-sharp code
right have our engine read the c-sharp
code or whatever system whatever runtime
we're using the compile c sharp code and
see what has been exposed to the editor
so what i'm talking about is basically
if we define a public
float or i don't know you don't have to
do it this way you can have a special
attribute for it called like speed um or
whatever right that's awful uh then what
i would expect to happen there is that
whatever entity that script is attached
to in like the editor properties for
that script you'd see oh look here's a
speed variable and it's modifiable
uh
over here right so the idea behind that
is i mean for the longest time obviously
there's been a lot of different
disciplines that go into making games
right you have engineers but then you
also have artists designers that kind of
stuff so
i mean c-sharp i would argue is pretty
simple it's not c plus plus right that's
why we don't really want to write our
code natively not just because it
becomes less about data like it's not
like a separate module we can load and
it's not like part of the game assets
the same way if it's actually native
code although of course it could be if
it's like a dll but anyway we're not
going to get into that the point is that
c-sharp is pretty accessible by most
people it's not that difficult to learn
i think at least in a scripting sense of
course language can be complex but if
you use what's required for scripting i
don't think it's that difficult
however providing tools for artists and
designers to be able to easily
manipulate things like again if you have
this complex script uh but then you
expose certain parameters that could be
used by artists or by designers very
easily of course it's easier for them to
click an entity and then modify
something like this i mean it's even
easier for engineers let's be honest but
like the point is this stuff is really
important because
without it like it would be way harder
to be able to edit things i mean back in
the day again if you you've had to get
an engineer for everything if you didn't
know how to write code right um it's not
like you're going to be in c plus plus
or c land dealing with memory
allocations and like pointers and
references and all of that stuff so a
reflection system is very important um
and it also means that these values can
be serialized right and they can be part
of your kind of editor data or your
scene entity data whatever um means if
if you want to change the speed from
five to six you don't need to recompile
the entire c-sharp dll if you're on
windows
you can just change the data that gets
sent to that variable at runtime so it's
pretty powerful and it's definitely very
um useful
um you know stuff like being able to
like manage the life cycle of the
c-sharp runtime so being able to unload
and reload assemblies so in hazel in
proper hazel when you hit play
it will reload the dll usually unless
you disable that option so if you're
kind of compiling you can compile in
visual studio
then you can just hit play and it will
load the latest script on demand now you
can see it's pretty quick if you've seen
devlogs it doesn't really take any time
at all so it is rather fast but being
able to kind of i'll just say loading
which again might not make um
[Music]
that much sense but just know that i'm
talking about specifically managing that
life cycle
loading life
um and then finally uh as i mentioned
like some kind of visual scripting
potentially could be on the tables
that's a really big stretch goal
um so let's move on from scripting now
the next thing we have
is physics
who doesn't love physics
so
this is also where the 2d nature comes
in because basically for physics as you
can imagine we're not going to be using
like nvidia physx or any kind of 3d
physics engine we're going to use
something called box 2d which i have
mentioned in the past this is a pretty
good 2d physics engine now 2d physics
engines in general are not the hardest
things in the world to write
like
it's actually quite interesting if you
delve into like the mathematics behind
the physics
and you'll probably see like physics
engines are always scary to people i
don't think they're the scariest things
in the world
unless you know nothing about physics or
anything um but obviously using a
library like box 2d i think is much
is a much smarter play i'm not going to
pretend to know how to write an
excellent physics library so um that's
basically what we'll be uh
kind of using and so that will be able
to fulfill pretty much all of our
physics needs now by physics i'm also
referring to collision right so just
being able to detect collision even so
that's something that box 2d can
obviously provide us um it needs to be
integrated with scripting meaning like
not only can i like retrieve like and
and with the ecs so not only can i like
retrieve a rigidbody component apply an
impulse to it and it will actually shoot
like the physics entity somewhere right
uh not only that but i also need to be
able to actually like receive callbacks
when entities or triggers have like
collided right so if there is a
collision
maybe a particular entity
wants to know about it so callbacks as
well um i guess i'll write that down
but that's important
um so that's the that's kind of that
part of it uh we might also potentially
have physics materials it's been a while
like box 2d also exists in proper hazel
so we have both 2d and 3d physics and
videophysx is what we use for 3d physics
i don't remember if we support like
physics materials for box 2d
um but we obviously want parameters to
go on to certain entities that are like
physics bodies so uh restitution you
know bouncing is like stuff like that
like how how much something weighs like
the mass uh that also needs to be
defined somehow so that's kind of editor
i guess ecs
integration
um and then you know joins constraints
all of that kind of stuff basically
everything that box 2d supports we want
to be able to expose and
and have people um
kind of uh manipulate those parameters
to achieve whatever physics stuff
they're trying to achieve so next up
we have a particle system
and also like gravity you know maybe you
want to make a game in space and you
want stuff to float
but again that's that's just that's just
a way of exposing kind of box 3d
parameters into
hazel
so particle systems oh man okay so 2d
particle systems again slightly easier
than 3d particle systems but uh you know
the main thing here is probably having
some kind of like vfx graph so this is a
node-based editor
which
we can use to define the flow of
particles and uh you know what maybe
triggers them how they react to things i
mean it doesn't have to be like a node
based system it can just be a set of
parameters but then you lose a bit of
like you lose a dimension basically like
the whole over time thing but maybe even
having if you feel really exciting you
could have curve editors so you could
have like color over time and you could
draw that um you know there's so much
stuff to do with like there is so much
stuff you could do with particles uh but
you know being able to support textures
animations all that kind of uh stuff
that you would expect to have there um
animations you know you could maybe
attach lights or things to them which
would affect certain shaders uh you know
being able to collide with things um
so usually collision is done uh
i guess
separately to like the physics system
although it can depend and then finally
you can move on to compute
so if you're really cool you can um move
a lot of your particle kind of
simulation uh code onto the gpu and do
it kind of asynchronously on the in like
in the compute queue in compute shaders
which is
usually pretty nice but anyway um so
particle system again very important if
we go back to hollow knight these things
floating around here they float they're
not static they are all particles right
so it can do a lot to
kind of increase the fidelity of a game
i guess it's not necessarily something
that you just need for explosions or
like rocket launches or smoke
just having particles floating around in
your world is huge um it does so much
for the ambiance so yeah super important
now i have a little section here called
editor but the real thing is no um
because i'm not going to talk about
everything that's going to go into the
editor because that's just wild but this
is more for some things that you may not
have considered such as an undo redo
system um the proper hazel doesn't even
have this yet right
i've had it on my to-do list for ages
but i just can't bring myself to do it
because it's gonna be a lot of work but
basically the editor needs to be very
much aware of every change that ever
happens to it and in this case how to
reverse it right um
that's very important and that requires
a little bit more
um you know thinking about how you write
code rather than just writing the bare
minimum code to achieve the desired
effect right so um that is something
that is best done early on we might
actually consider doing this pretty soon
for the game engine series but basically
yeah that whole undo redo thing
um super important
uh
but the i think most of it you you
really have to like just look at it as a
as a collection of tools right like you
know you might in your toolbox you might
have a hammer a drill a screwdriver all
of that stuff that's what an editor is
it's all these different panels that do
different things and they manipulate
different data they come together into
this big tool um called the editor right
um or we call it hazelnut
so
uh
that's kind of what it is again even if
we go back all the way to
um you know what do we start with uh
this kind of stuff textual stuff right
if you import a texture that's an atlas
how do you define the cells right that's
the tool um so there's all these
different things that that exist um
you know as far as the editor goes and
it's it's hard to even start talking
about all the systems everything that
i've mentioned so far that needs a ui
well that's going to be that's going to
be editor stuff
speaking of ui this is a good transition
let's go down here user interface
also something that we haven't talked
about um
i actually had this written down a bit
later but we'll talk about it now so the
main thing with ui is text rendering
right so you want to be able to render
text this is something we haven't
touched at all
um text rendering is uh can be fairly
simple can be fairly complex you know
choose your poison um it depends on how
you want to do it we want to do it well
so we probably want to use signed
distance fields we don't want to
just simply rasterize something from
free type into a texture atlas and it's
good to go that is uh is fine but it's
not going to get you the nice crisp text
that you probably want so we'll probably
look at doing it you know using sdfs
there's a few good libraries online
that can kind of generate texture
atlases even for us that we can then use
as part of that um because there's a lot
more to ui rendering than text of course
uh layouts right so a layout system i'll
say this um i haven't really thought
about how exactly i want to do this in
hazel because there are also libraries
that let you like for example define
layouts in css and then it will do stuff
to it but like a good example is um i
mean if we look at hollow knight this ui
up here right so let's but that's a good
example of ui that's something we call a
hud heads-up display that's just
overlaid on our game as we play the game
there's a few things going on here right
there's actually a lot of things going
on here first of all the alignment of
this we want it to be in the top left
corner
no matter what resolution we're playing
at right so i mean it could be like the
screen could be um you know a 4 3
display for some reason it could be an
18 by 9 like ultra wide monitor right
and we still want it to be here right we
want stuff that we've positioned in the
middle to be in the middle that's
difficult you guys have done css know
how difficult it is to position
something in the middle and it's
probably easier to do like in c plus
plus programmatically but um my point is
there's a lot of layout stuff that needs
to be considered here um but also it's
not just the layout of like what stuff
gets aligned to which by the way could
be you know set at like 50 pixels or it
could be five percent right like you can
you should be able to define these
things and change them but then
um if we look at hollow knight again
there's a lot more stuff going on here
like this uh kind of soul indicator
those of you who have played holiday
know what i'm talking about otherwise
this might be um not that good you
should play the game though it's really
i'm still playing it i've just finished
crystal peak
um it's it's brutal but it's an
excellent game and it's just got such a
good vibe to it anyway so
this is like the soul indicator this
kind of moves right so it's animated
it's it's also a this level
it also depends on how much soul you
have at the moment these are basically
your lives and these also have to change
um they go empty there are blue ones
that you can get right like it's it's
very much dynamic and it changes this is
the amount of geo you have it's like a
currency um that also is some text
rendering that is positioned in a in a
particular location and you need to be
able to obviously control that value
through your metagame through c sharp so
um holo knight is made in unity by the
way so uh it's a good example of how to
lay things out if you're used to unity
um but anyway uh the point is that a lot
goes into this little thing but then
we're not just talking about like the
hud which is what that is uh there's a
lot more to ui i mean not just hard
elements like that stuff but we also
want to obviously support menus and menu
screens all right so like the pause menu
when the pause menu happens it happens
in the middle i don't know i think
hollow knight does is i think it
it blurs everything out in the
background right so we need to be able
to have a full screen kind of blur
that's usually just a ui kind of overlay
that blurs whatever's behind it right
because ui is usually rendered last so
you know stuff like that um menu screen
yeah being able to have a main menu that
we can go to options menu with like a
slider for like the audio level you know
all of that ui has to be there uh being
able to transition between screens
animations
you know ui animations man oh
you know
there's so much stuff
um
ui is very very complicated people who
think that ui is easy i would vouch that
it is almost as complicated as 3d
rendering there's so much stuff that
goes in it yeah and an um an inventory
screen right so being able to have an
inventory uh where you can like um you
know have different items and go through
that like
there's a lot of stuff i know when i i
don't even want to talk about it's
making me upset so moving on um
so we touched on the editor before i
went into this user interface but also i
guess the other important thing is the
runtime right so we want to be able to
um
this is an epic video we want to be able
to uh
basically hit play to play the game
right seems uh simple but this play
button is like a lot of a lot of stuff
has to happen there and obviously we
need to be able to support it so um yeah
being able to basically play
right but also have a standalone player
so play in editor
but then also stand-alone
right this is very important because if
we can't play the game what are we doing
um we need to be able to play the game
as a standalone thing
now realistically like if we do break
down what happens there usually it will
just load a scene so if you have a menu
upload the menu scene if you have a if
you just jump straight into the game you
load the game scene um and you basically
play it by starting up like the physics
world and then just running the c script
so they have oncreate functions then
they have on update functions you just
basically run those um and that is your
game right so it's not that difficult um
in terms of like uh you know what you
need to do you just need to hit play on
the physics world basically and then hit
play um hit call the right c sharp
functions obviously there's other engine
systems like audio that need to also be
potentially initiated
and initialized right
but that's kind of for the most part
what we expect from a runtime now this
isn't about distribution we'll get to
that later um and about like actually
shipping the game
um okay a little little blob here which
i might actually put here serialization
right so now when i say serialization
i'm not talking about
saving our level this has nothing to do
with the editor i'm talking about
runtime serialization so what this is is
i want to be able to save my game right
i don't want the player to lose their
progress and start from scratch every
time they launch my game that's
obviously very weird uh for certain
games um i want to be able to have a
save game right so that needs to be
like the engine usually will provide a
way to do that and uh possibly even by
using c-sharp's reflection system
um and then that will actually serialize
something on disk like a file or it'll
go up into the cloud right so
say games are important but even for
something simple like you want to be
able to have like a high score right
even if you make space invaders i want
to be able to um serialize my high score
so the next time i launch the game i can
see what it is and i can see if i can
beat it so uh this can all be done
technically speaking this can be done
outside of the game engine right if you
have
um if you're using c sharp c sharp has a
library you you can write files there's
no reason why you can't so uh that stuff
can be done by that but usually an
engine will provide its way of doing
this and that can be a little bit more
kind of standardized i guess
so that's serialization pretty quick
um
the other thing is i don't know if i
should even mention this but cinematics
right so cut scenes right i want to be
able to and obviously nothing to do with
3d but like i want to be able to um you
know i've got my player here i want to
just take the control away from the
player and maybe pan this camera over
here to show them something um maybe
someone comes there's a bit of dialogue
and subtitles and maybe i want this to
be like two three five aspect ratio
because it's all cinematic but right
like there's there's a lot of like to
make this stuff happen you need to
basically create like a
a movie maker or some kind of like after
effects style tool like you you want to
have you know various layers that are
entities you want to have a timeline you
want to be able to set keyframes
there's a lot of stuff i don't know if
we'll do this like we
want to i want to but
we'll definitely do this for proper
hazel but um
just another thing to do man just
another thing to do
uh we've done ui uh let's talk about
audio
so audio is also immensely important
audio is something people forget about
but more or less people don't know how
complicated audio can be can be very
complicated at the very base right we
want to be able to play back audio files
so playback right i have a wav file
probably packaged into like a og or some
other kind of file format but we have um
we have a wav file for example i want to
play it
we need to be able to trigger audio
events um usually this will be set up
and they'll be like events actually set
up in your scene or in your project and
then you can trigger those and those
mapped to assets and those assets which
are those wav files they can have a
bunch of parameters on them such as how
loud they are you know if they've got
any filters or effects on them that's
the other thing um another thing that
happens in celeste as an example is when
you do go underwater the sound changes
[Music]
so as the music is playing and you're
under water it just gets all kind of
muffled like it's the high frequency
just all cut out it's like a low-pass
filter um
you know that's something that you want
to be able to do dynamically right but
also stuff like reverb delay you know
maybe i don't know about eq and stuff
but um you know you can
having those kind of effects
very i think that i i think it's very
important i think sounds very important
um you know you could do like mixing um
mixing which means basically having
different audio channels that you can
control the volume of separately uh you
could have audio busses where you can
send like so you have like a reverb bus
and everything
lots of stuff you could do um you know
being able to stream in those assets so
when you're playback you want to be able
to stream them in maybe you have a 10
minute ambient sound file you don't want
to decode that whole thing and load it
into ram at once you might want to just
read it off disk buffer it and you know
play what you get
um
yeah i mean you could do a lot of you
could do a lot like having a node edit
of sound actually our um sound guy on on
the hazel team j he has done an amazing
job with audio and hazel and he's i mean
this is what he's currently working on
he's working on this like node editor
for hazel's audio system so
that's a great uh that's a great look at
just how far you can push this stuff
you can push all of this extremely far
and that's kind of the problem but
anyway moving on uh so i'll talk about
the asset system a little bit right so
an asset system for a game engine like
the most important thing of an asset
system um we're not going to talk about
like um like a virtual file system and
other stuff but like honestly it's just
to be able to load and unload assets as
they're required
right so i want to be able to not
necessarily like just because i
reference an asset or just because i
mention an asset i might not want to
load the whole thing
immediately right because obviously a
game can have many different levels
especially if you're talking about a
game like uh hollow knight or a big 2d
game this game's huge right there's so
many different areas if
and and you have all these textures you
have all these like rather high quality
textures right these are not things that
um you can just keep all in memory or in
your gpu memory all the time it's just
not gonna work out so you need to have a
system to load and unload them as
they're being used
um you know streaming assets in and
memory mapping so what that means is the
streaming
memory map
so what that means is basically um
instead of like if you have a
a 500 megabyte texture that you want to
get onto the gpu hypothetically uh
instead of loading in that whole like
500 megabyte texture to cpu ram and then
loading it to gpu
right gpu cpu you can instead memory map
it so you have like a rolling window you
roll through it you buffer it and then
that way you never use 500 megabytes of
cpu ram and you can get into the gpu
faster because you don't really need it
to stick around in the cpu so memory
mapping is very important as well um for
like you know something a bit more
serious and it will massively cut down
load times as well because you don't
need to be
necessarily loading that whole file
again if it is a format that does
require the whole file to be loaded that
usually would never exist in
a runtime for the editor maybe but again
i'm more thinking about the runtime here
um yeah packaging
so like maybe creating a binary blob or
blobs
we'll talk about packaging a little bit
later so
binary
blob but yeah that also kind of needs to
exist um another thing that i wrote down
was edit a hot reloading so this is kind
of nice
very nice system to have very easy to
set up basically what that means is that
when an asset changes the like a windows
file watcher for example will pick that
up it'll be aware that hey a file has
changed on disk and you can
automatically initiate like a reload
from that so an example is i'm editing a
png file in photoshop i hit control s
magically my engine has the updated
texture right um because it's got a file
washer it's where it's changed and it's
re reloaded the asset you might want to
be able to turn that off as well but
it's uh it's definitely very useful to
have and iteration time just go through
the roof with that um all right my next
step is platform support so
with this i'm not just talking about
like what we need to do
right to have support for like windows
mac and linux
right i would like to support all of
these platforms at a minimum eventually
although at the moment we are focusing
on windows um that this is all true
being able to support all this stuff but
um you also need to be able to support
different versions of windows so
different diff win
there are a lot of different versions of
windows they have different run times
they have different like c plus plus
well runtime that's what i'm what i'm
talking about you need to be able to
support all of this and be sure that the
stuff that you're using is widely is as
widely available as possible or at least
provide alternative paths maybe compile
different binaries um for this this
falls a little bit into into actual
distribution but that's also important
right be aware of that but also
different hardware so like different
gpus so um do you support nvidia uh what
about amd
what about intel these have these the
drivers that kind of you know you use
here have a big impact potentially um
you know hazel for the longest time
didn't like proper hazel didn't run on
amd gpus until i set up an amd computer
behind me with a 6800 xt where i could
actually
develop for that right um and that was
partially due to me just not like i had
some mistakes there that the nvidia
driver was happy with um but technically
the vulcan specification was like no
um
but also there were just some things
that worked differently that i didn't
expect so
um this is yeah it's important to
actually make sure that you do support
different platforms and in this section
i've also put things like controllers
and game pads right so these are like i
guess human interface devices right like
heads um these are more like uh actual
uh you know hardware that you would use
for input
but they're also very important like um
i i couldn't imagine playing hollow
knight on a keyboard i've actually also
got the game on steam and i played it
with the keyboard a little bit i think
i'd probably plug it in controller to
play that game because certain games
just work really well platform is a
great you know there's no need for
precise
first person shooter aiming with the
mouse
controllers are great and uh you
definitely want to support them
especially if you know you want to ship
maybe on it on the nintendo switch and
it's not just about windows mac and
linux so
yeah you also need to be kind of aware
of that and i've
put that in here is anyone tired yet i
am um networking
networking
so networking is an interesting thing
because i don't think that we're
like we're not going to support
multiplayer as part of this series as
part of the game engine series
um
proper hazel has some plans for that but
we're not going to support multiplayer
as part of this series probably almost
overwhelmingly it's just out of scope
right this is just too much
but um by networking i'm not just
referring to like real time or
turn-based multiplayer i'm talking about
just being able to interface with the
network right so being able to
download files like right like being
able to download assets maybe updating
the game even something as simple as
having a news screen on the homepage you
open the game and then it's like news
guess what update 1.4 is out or like you
know just being able to communicate with
the outside world networking right very
important um
pulling configuration files off the
internet an example is uh back when i
worked at ea we showed a game called
near for speed no limits which was a
mobile game that actually used to pull
its tiering settings off of servers that
we had so what that means is that
basically we could we had like a
database of phones like an iphone 6 this
was
back in the day um and we could set like
what you know what shadow resolution
should be used for that device what you
know what a viewport scale should be
used for that device um you know we
could set all this stuff kind of
remotely and the phone when it connected
could download all those configuration
settings that way we could tweak stuff
after release it's a bit different with
mobile i'm not sure what what how how
difficult it is like on steam and stuff
but
you know especially with apple it can
take a while to be able to push an
update right and so that's why having
your own updating system your own way to
download assets and configuration files
is definitely very important um you know
if for nothing else in control of like
uh of the content that you're actually
displaying in your game you might want
to do a special like christmas or
halloween update or something right um
and you might want to
do something special for that basically
so that's important um you could also
fit in you know if it was mobile maybe
ads but also like uh
analytics telemetry we're not going to
talk about that i don't think i want to
put any of that into hazel at least not
for the time being but that can be
useful as well you can see how many
people
have crashed their game and why right
you can send that back to a server um
that's
quite useful for diagnosing problems so
diagnostics and stuff can be can be used
there as well
um
all right let's talk about optimization
briefly we're almost done
you guys are enjoying like hopefully now
it makes sense maybe while i'm like
maybe let's not do 3d because yeah i
hope this makes sense um
optimization
so
i like doing this more towards the end
because then i know what i'm doing and
i'm not going to waste time optimizing
stuff that then gets stripped or removed
immediately right but uh the biggest
change to um the biggest the biggest
change and the biggest kind of thing i
guess with optimization is multi
threading right so making it making the
engine multi-threaded at the moment
hazel uh
[Music]
hazel
um game engine hazel 2d i was like hey
game engine series hazel 2d entirely
runs on on a single thread right there
is no threads for literally anything i
as far as far as i'm aware i don't think
so
um
[Music]
this is uh definitely not optimal right
because
computers don't just have one core uh
computers and most devices have a lot
more than one core
what this means is that we can take
advantage of that and we can split our
workload along different cores and the
thing is i'm not just talking about like
you know spinning up a thread uh to do
some work temporarily like a job thread
right like maybe from c sharp you want
to do some ai simulation and you want
that to be multi-threaded sure just use
the c-sharp api i'm talking about
specifically the engine core itself so a
very popular model is to have a separate
thread for example for rendering right
a separate thread for like physics
simulation separate thread for audio and
that's actually mandatory but like you
know spreading out the workloads a
little bit so that you don't have to
kind of bottleneck yourself by just
having uh a single thread so um as i
mentioned with the render thread that's
a very popular model to do a lot of
people think that that doesn't work with
opengl for some reason because opengl is
single threaded opengl has to be
entirely has to entirely exist on one
thread but that doesn't have to be the
main thread right so you can have your
main thread and then that can spin off a
render thread whose entire job is just
to process opengl commands which still
have a considerable cpu cost and you can
kind of offload that to a different core
that's a very popular architecture for
pretty much every game engine
so that's an example of what we would do
to kind of
basically speed up hazel a lot
um
gpu offloading i also wrote down so gpu
offloading again like i mean
it depends what it is um a lot of things
you can a lot of operations you can
potentially move to the gpu uh if you
have that it depends if your cpu or gpu
bound we're not going to dive into that
but that's just a possibility for
optimization um the other thing is you
do want to be aware of bottlenecks and
slowdowns in your engine so you need
some kind of profiling now we have some
weird rubbish profiler i think in in
hazel 2d at the moment hazel the proper
hazel uses uh something called optic
we'll probably be using that in hazel 2d
as well
i've actually like the video that i put
out recently about
diagnosing performance issues in hazel
that was using optics if you want to
take a look at that and see what it
looks like then that's pretty recent
video
um but yeah so that's also something
that
um needs to be done for sure
i think we've this is it man finally we
are at the end and the end is basically
packaging and distribution i'm just
going to call this distribution
uh
too tired
there we go distribution
so how do we ship our game
um there's a lot of stuff that
potentially has to change for that right
um so how do we distribute it
that
that's that's a question in and of
itself um but uh
the biggest change probably is the use
of custom formats so why would you want
custom file formats for all of our
assets basically what i'm talking about
so custom formats so
there's a few reasons for this first of
all protection right you don't want to
just have all of your assets all of your
art assets all of the intellectual
property potential that you've built
just be
copyable right you also potentially
don't want it to be changeable like you
don't want someone to open your png file
in photoshop draw something on it and
then play a game that's weird right so
protection is is a realist is a real
thing that you might want um file size
right so certain files can be quite
large and you might want to compress
them
um
so that's important as well as just
speed right most file formats that we
use today png jpeg that kind of stuff um
they're not built for game engines so
they can take a little bit of time to
decode um also you may have known
noticed hopefully that we use um you
know for the editor side of things for
the editor we use uh text-based file
formats usually so our scenes are
text-based they're in yaml
a lot of our kind of files are because
they're meant for
like development use and you don't want
to
merge binary files together but for this
you need binary files right so switching
to binary file formats um and then
trying to optimize for these things is
very important so speaking of which um
in terms of like speed and stuff
compression so like things like lz4 you
know mel's at ham zed lib
i don't remember what else there is um
like right there's a few others um
uh the this is useful because you can
compress files um i don't think i need
to tell you that it'll make them smaller
um and then based on you know what which
which library you use basically you have
trade-offs usually between file size and
speed um but that's basically um
important these are all obviously
lossless compression libraries um but
also like not just compression with this
stuff but also gpu texture formats a lot
of people are unaware of this but
um gpu
texture compression but like um
you know
the way that we use textures and the way
that we've used textures and most people
i think who are learning like rendering
and stuff use textures is they take
their png file or whatever they load it
they get all the raw pixels um in rgba
right which could be 32 bits each for
each channel if it's like in float if
it's an hdr or just you know one byte
per channel that's four bytes per pixel
and then they just
just into vram right and there you go
now the problem is that um if you've
actually tried to ever make something
substantial
and then think about distributing it you
might notice that you very quickly run
out of gpu memory like very quickly
especially if you're working um maybe on
a 3d game that has cube maps and then
they have mips and then they might be
hdr all right i mean you can easily have
textures that are like over half a
gigabyte um that's not acceptable uh and
again if we look at all of the stuff
that we have here there's a lot right
there are a lot of these rather large
textures now
again if you have a whole world of that
and you want to keep your not just your
file sizes down but vram down right then
you need to use a gpu texture
compression format
um
uh such as um i mean what are the big
ones like astc
um etc dxt5 off the top of my head
there's there's others as well pvrtc i
think is for power pc or whatever but um
there's like these are these are all
compression formats which are pretty
cool because it means that you can
compress your textures into this format
and then you take this binary data that
is compressed you don't decompress it
when loading it you literally put it on
into gpu vram compressed and then as
it's sampled as it's used it really it
like it deals with the format basically
so um that stuff is is awesome it is
lossy usually um a little bit it depends
on which settings you use obviously but
um this is very vital i think for this
distribution
um so uh yeah gpu test compression
format is very important
um
i've written down platforms platform
support i guess i covered that but yeah
like um oh right what i meant is like
you know if you're
shipping on mobile you might want to
actually support the platform meaning
like um push notifications which might
use the os api
um if you're shipping on steam there's
like steamworks and there's like a few
steam has its own apis for a lot of
things like steam achievements for
example you might want to integrate with
that so i'll say platform
support
oh yeah this is a big one that i don't
know why i put this into distribution
because you should probably be thinking
about this before that but localization
who doesn't like some localization i
don't know if it's spelled with a z
usually but i'm australian so
localization with an asset is i should
have spelt a lot of things within it
with an s but i didn't for you so um but
anyway localization so
um what this means is uh basically
supporting other languages right um not
just languages but like localization
usually refers to supporting other
languages so again if you have a main
menu instead of having like play
um and then all the other kind of
options you might want to translate that
into japanese or like russian or german
or any other language right so you need
support for basically like a database of
strings right so strings are very
important in general for an engine i
didn't put this in because that's boring
but
i didn't didn't put in things like
actually a big one in optimization would
have been
memory meaning
be aware of the memory you're allocating
maybe have certain like ring buffers or
like stack allocators frame allocators
that for memory that lasts just one
frame
has a lifetime of one frame you know
there's a lot of
stuff that you might want to do with
that but anyway localization yeah so you
have this entire kind of string database
where um you basically instead of having
a string ever in your code base you have
a key
or you have you request some kind of
like id of a string and then you get
back whichever one you need to based on
the language settings so that's
important to to have
right but um also this can have deeper
kind of implications because like i mean
not only do you have to make sure that
all your fonts support the right glyphs
if you are dealing with something like
japanese or chinese or i mean even
languages like russian and german like
you know have german has this like kind
of it's
double s is what they write a lot of
times these days for some reason i don't
know i went to school in germany so i
know a bit i also speak russian
russian has a lot of stuff i mean
umlauts and german as well but then you
have russian umlauts you have um what's
a russian character that doesn't exist
anywhere else bear
like i know i thought of that one but
like there's a lot of different um you
know glyphs uh that you might have to
have it's not just for like asian
languages um uh a lot of languages
obviously have that and then also um
certain languages like hebrew and arabic
you know they read right to left so you
need to be sure that your alignment is
correct and that you're rendering glyphs
in the right order not in this order
because you only are aware of the
language you speak so there's a lot of
stuff that can happen with localization
but i think that localization is also
i mean i don't think um
localization is not just about languages
and translations it's also about things
like
um you know maybe you have uh your
latest kind of save games and they have
a date associated with them at a date
and a time so do you write the date like
uh you know day month year
right or do you write it in i think only
america writes month to year for some
reason um but like uh i picked something
on ambi i was going to pick a value that
was like yeah 15 because then that way
you can tell but um you know which how
do you write your date based on what
region you're in because obviously if
you've shipped your game to america and
they're like eight eight that's the
dumbest example possible
the one case in which it works but
anyway um you do something like that
like hang on a minute it's not even
october yet um it's uh well actually no
in this case it's august man i'm really
failing this but they might look at this
and be like dude i did not play this
game in october but you're like no you
played it on the 10th of august so it
doesn't make sense um so that's
important 24 hour time i don't know if
people uh i don't know if this is like
necessarily a localization thing um i
just like 24 hour time in general i
usually have that on but i remember in
school in germany um you know we usually
wrote time is 24 hour time but i'm sure
that people do use pm there it's not
like the date where everyone
writes the date in whatever you know
region they exist exist in
um and then another thing off the top of
my head was like currency and like uh
you know delimiters i guess for that so
like if you have a million dollars right
how do you write the separating thing
and then you have like um
zero cents here right so uh you know we
kind of in i think probably most of like
well america and like
asia i guess as well i'm not 100 sure we
write commas here and then a dot here
right but then um you know european
countries if they were using like euros
or whatever um you would write dots for
these instead of commas and then you
have a comma for this kind of thing and
then you'd put like i don't know like
the euro symbol which also by the way
goes on the end not at the start so
there's all these kinds of uh
localization things that you have to do
um and then finally we have literally
like stripping uh stripping like debug
symbols so do not ship debug symbols and
other kind of things you might want to
do make sure you compile with actual
full optimization maybe potentially
check out a variety of different
compilers to see what gives you the
fastest code
but like you know stripping uh symbols
and just in general like production code
so what this means
and production code so what this means
is um
uh not just like um specifically debug
kind of things that should only exist in
debug builds or like you know like
logging but um well not logging doesn't
just exist in debug builds but i'm not
just talking about that i'm talking
about like any kind of production code
that you might use so for example maybe
you have like a cheat menu that you can
pop up to like progress to a level to
give yourself a million gold because
obviously you're testing the game all of
that should be stripped um anything
there shouldn't be anything to do with
the editor most likely right so the
editor editor stuff should just not
exist physically in the binary um it
shouldn't be accessible you shouldn't be
calling things that shouldn't be called
um it can be a little bit difficult to
separate uh you know your kind of
production code meaning the code you use
during the game's production and then
finally
what you actually distribute and ship to
people so that's important usually
code doesn't end up being fully stripped
but at least make sure that you don't
have debug symbols so that you can't so
there's harder to reverse engineer
everything
um and uh you know stuff like debug
menus
um cheat menus uh all of that stuff as
well as just unnecessary functions even
that might be called for verification i
mean assess and verify should be removed
by this point anyway but you a lot of
the time that's why c plus plus is so
nice you can just pre-press the
pre-process all of that out and even not
compile certain files if you're building
in distribution
anyway how do i zoom out um this is it
guys this is uh this is the plan um
i i don't think i've missed anything
what a long video i hope i hope this is
this is fine i hope you guys made it
this far
um but like this is as far as i can tell
this is the complete plan
every not every single one of these
things but most of these things um we'll
have to make it into hazel 2d and into
this game engine series project and into
proper hazel as well
so
um
yeah
uh that is the state of things so anyway
i hope you guys enjoy this video i won't
keep you any longer
um don't forget to leave a like button
don't forget to hit the like button
below please and um
patreon.com best way to help support
this it's a lot of work um it's only
possible with your support and as i
mentioned if you do want to help support
the development of proper hazel get
access to all that source code
um then uh your support would be greatly
appreciated it's the only reason why
this is possible right
um
i would uh not be doing this more or
less full time
if it wasn't for you guys so i'm
internally grateful for that and i'm
also i'm excited to do all this stuff to
be honest and um
hopefully you guys are as well please
leave your thoughts as well in the
comment section below i'm really
interested to hear uh what the response
is going to be like to this i'm a little
nervous but to be honest i feel better
after this huge presentation because
like
it it honestly like to be blunt it
honestly doesn't even matter what you
guys think like
i
i can't do this if i'm gonna do this in
3d as well and if somehow magically this
series is somehow still going on when
all of this is done and we've actually
shipped stuff and it's stable
then maybe we can look at 3d because
i'll run out of things to do with my
life which seems unlikely but
i hope that you understand at the moment
especially for a game engine series not
a 3d graphics programming series um this
is
where i'm at this is what i need to do
this is the decision i need to make for
myself and
and i hope you guys are okay with that
thank you all for watching love you all
and i'll see you next time goodbye